I guess it's Matt code tech and
tutorials I don't know what I'm doing
I'm just making random symbols I want to
expand on a topic I saw a video on
recently another youtuber programmer
forest knight made a video about time
boxing and it is I just want to say
extremely accurate I don't know what's
going on a beard here's a little thinner
on one side I don't care
yeah time time boxing watch his video
and really absorb that he he nails it
and I wish I would have seen that video
before I started my last job but hey the
video just came out I'd never really
heard anyone talk about that directly
before but it is extremely relevant and
it will save your save your life save
your job so I'll tell you a little quick
story and tell you kind of how it
relates basically and you can't spend
unlimited time on every program when
you're doing some kind of duty or job
and have to get just some amount of code
done or something done and you you just
can't you need to stick to some kind of
time box you need to have a limit you
need to need to have like a list of
things that you need to get done within
a certain amount of time and you need to
pick them apart
one by one you need to say okay I need
to build this element and I've gotten
Howard to do it or two hours to do it
and you spend that time and you need to
gauge very carefully how you're doing if
you're an hour end and you don't feel
like you're gonna hit it get it done by
two hours you need to go check with
someone else who knows how to do this or
should know you think knows how to do
this as soon as possible because you
know an hour of time of really focusing
in on a problem is enough is enough time
to do some digging online read through
the core documentation of it and try to
work and try to hammer out a little
example or a build or a sample and then
you should be able to take the next hour
to clean it up and make it nice and it's
just kind of a random scenario your your
time limits will
in this example that's what we're going
with so within the first hour if you
can't get a little basic example of it
working you don't feel like you have the
concept understood you got to go ask for
help and have someone explain it maybe
that'll take five minutes ten minutes 15
minutes who knows it could take longer
but what happens right there at that
point at that one hour point is you've
let someone else know that you're you're
having a little trouble here and a lot
of companies handle this by having their
little stand-up meetings every day and
that kind of gives you a full day to
work on things before you are forced to
come out with your problem and it's not
like you have to reveal your problem but
if you don't it looks really bad on you
because later you say you reveal your
code or whatever it is and it's just not
done and then your boss is like so what
do you what do you even do it I didn't
hear anything from you it's just not
done and then makes you look really bad
it doesn't make sense for a company or
even yourself working on your own
company to stay in the same position on
the same thing without making any
progress because a lot of times when a
concept is hard to get it's because
you're starting in the middle or at the
top level and you didn't get the basic
level like if you try to do
multiplication and division without
learning addition and subtraction first
it's gonna be ridiculously hard because
you're not gonna understand the
underlying concepts of you know
multiplying is just basically hiding
that many times and so that's that's a
way to look at it so a lot of times when
you're stuck on something that hard and
then you reveal your problem someone
else will be like oh okay you need to
look at this first and then you look at
that and it all clicks and you're good
so the point of the timeboxing is you
set limits on how much time you're
spending on stuff so you don't end up
wasting whole days all weeks everybody's
time working on something that
ultimately isn't gonna get solved
without you going to someone else so
being a coder is surprisingly social you
always hear about programmers and coders
being like you know basement dwellers
never talking to anybody but to be a
good one I mean maybe maybe some of them
are fine doing it completely solo but to
be a good one that you often have to be
really social and really improve your
social skills because you got to learn
from others and people aren't gonna want
to teach you or won't even know you need
taught if they don't know you have a
problem now we're in a world of YouTube
where you can see stuff like this and
other a lot of other stuff a lot of
articles online and often you can find
something that hits home but more often
than not at least from what I found you
cannot find something that hits home and
so that's why you really need the social
skills and to not be afraid to go ask
somebody for help now one of the
problems I've ran into recently is I
have no one to go to for help I'm
working on things where I I don't know a
single person in real life that
understands the concept and can explain
it or break it down and that that is
troubling there's a little bit of
information online it's scattered it's
not done quite how I would prefer to do
it or something like that so it just
makes it hard and you know you just have
to break it down and it's important I
think in those cases to still time box
only spend a certain amount of time on
it
when you feel like working on it and
just you know set some sort of timer a
lot of people do the Pomodoro stuff I I
found that Pomodoro didn't work for me I
tried in a lot of different ways it
basically just annoyed me and I just
stopped doing it it didn't make me
actually seem to work more so I had to
find some sort of other motivation and I
think my underlying motivation is well
I've got a couple things I've set some
limits where look I just have to do this
every day and if I don't I'm not gonna
beat myself up about it but I know very
well that if I don't do this every day
I'm further away from finishing
this software I want to finish and every
time I at least spend some time on it
and try to understand something that I'm
moving forward and that's that's good
I've also set a limit where well while
Classics been out for a while now and I
was addicted to Wow a long time ago when
I first came out and it was such a great
game and I so wanted to experience it
again but I didn't I just held back and
said look I just firmly told myself no
you're not getting a subscription unless
you finished this large chunk of code
and this thing this feature that I've
been stuck on from a little game engine
is the limiting factor here so when I do
finish it and when it does work good
I'll play some well but until then I
mean there's other games I can play that
aren't as addictive but if I get stuck
in the well rabbit hole or sucked into
the rabbit hole I know my heart's of
finishing this this software in a timely
manner are going to go down because well
I've learned from experience before I've
spent way too much time on well before
and you know it's fun it's a it's a
honestly well everyone's gonna have
varying opinions on this but I thought
it was a great life I absolutely loved
playing well back when it was and it's
prime for me I thought that was some of
the best experience of my life
I still have ten years later or however
long it's been - even more than that now
I still have real-life friends that I
made online from rating it Wow and
they're some of the coolest most
down-to-earth people I never would have
expected to meet otherwise and that's
that's something so I'm not bashing that
in any way although you know your
experience may vary because you know
there's people that didn't retain any
friends and played at a ton but that you
know it's just different for everyone it
depends what your goals are and if you
play a healer or not let's be real here
yeah that's that's probably why I made
friends it's cuz I played a healer and
when I started in you know people loved
healers give them all the gear to keep
me alive oh man we pulled too many stuff
and there's too much stuff and somehow
the healer kept us alive friend this guy
for life yeah it's that kind of stuff so
the important thing is to time box what
you're working on whether it's at work
or whether it's on your own stuff just
take everything that Forest Knight says
in his videos and I'll link it somewhere
maybe it'll be up here maybe will be
down there take that hall to heart
because it is it is so true and I really
wish that I saw that video earlier and
forest Knight if you see this video
thank you
that's uh something everybody needs to
know in here all right peace out you
guys see in the next video don't forget
to like to help this with the YouTube
algorithm and subscribe if you want to
see more content from me I'm gonna
continue making videos and make a lot of
tutorials some rants some talks try to
prepare people for the real world a
little bit help you advance and I really
really would like to do this more to do
that I have to get some support so
anything I can get I appreciate whether
it be it likes a sub a comment thank you
and I also do have a patreon and worked
on much yet but you are welcome to
donate and I will be doing something as
soon as I do get some donations I would
decided what I'm gonna do with it
there's just so many options so many
possibilities of things I could put in
there and do you know I gotta really
make sure I'm willing to do what I say
I'm gonna do a lot of people will say
we'll post our source code if you donate
so much and we'll do things every week
with some cert people credits at the end
of the video I don't know so I'm willing
to hear some opinions on what might work
there alright guys peace out see in the
next video take care of yourselves and
have a good day